[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible can Marino who I love from so
many things party down uh Wanderlust
he's one of my absolute favorites here
is a little taste for the longest time
and I never thought about it and you're
gonna make fun of me I am not I promise
and then somebody corrected me and I
felt like a fool
right I say I would say Let Me Tell You
souvenir what is it I would say
I would say souvenir
[Music]
and and I'm not making fun of you I'm
done writing I'm delighting and I got
Sylvan here I'm so excited for us to get
into this episode guys as you can tell
if you're watching this on the video I'm
recording it in a hotel because I am on
the road if you would like to see me
while I'm doing stand up go to
petehomes.com we're about to add even
more cities to this tour they've been so
great I'm here in Portland it was
incredible and if you like this show why
not try a Pete's pick Pete's picks are
products that support the show but I
actually use and I actually love
especially when I'm touring I have been
swearing by Magic Mike I'm gonna be
honest I had two shows last night and it
was a two magic mind sort of day for
those of you who don't know what magic
mind is it is a tiny little magical
Elixir that gives you better focus on
your work and be more creative and drink
less coffee it is a mix of 12 functional
ingredients including matcha new
atropics that help you focus and
adaptogens that help you fight off
stress it is basically my little secret
formula that makes me feel creative in
the flow dialed in happy and ready to go
I've been drinking way less coffee I've
been noticing that coffee makes my teeth
grit together my my fists clench magic
mine is not like that don't think of
like uh all jacked up dialed in not
wired in that flow State it's like
athletes have Gatorade now creative
types have Creator Aid you get 30 more
done on average that's five to seven
hours of thirty percent more
productivity after drinking I just did
the show in San Francisco and a fan came
up to me and said thank you for telling
us about magic mine it's this is facts
she was like it absolutely changed my
mind I was like right I just had one
that's part of why the show was so good
gives me access to my brain gives me
just the right amount of energy and just
enough adaptogens to help curve curb
that stress and help me do what I need
to do with a sharp mind steady energy
immune support and less stress it is
incredible fights off ADD symptoms
fights off procrastination fights off
brain fog and fatigue and gets you into
that flow State and we had a special
offer for weirdos from our friends at
Magic mine go to
www.magicmind.com weird and use the
discount code weird to get 20 off your
first order and show your support of the
show that's magicmine dot Co slash weird
promo code weird at checkout for twenty
percent off and show your support of
this show we're also brought To Us by
our friend at meandies which I'm
currently wearing I'm wearing like a
like a Hawaiian pineapple uh me undies
PJ pant or lounge pant which I
absolutely love you know that feeling
when you get uh when your crush texts
you unexpectedly or when you make
powerful prolonged eye contact eye
contact with that cute Barista at your
local coffee shop well that's how it
feels wearing the new limited edition me
Andy's Valentine's Day collection add
some heat to your v-day with me undies
and get 20 off your first purchase plus
get free standard shipping and free
returns when you go to meandies.com
weird Val and I heard about me undies on
another podcast and we did a complete
overhaul of our PJ pants or lounge pants
and the underwear top details mostly our
Tails top details Complete re-haul
because they are the softest best
fitting in my opinion the best pattern
the best looking either classy like just
like a solid color that looks great and
fits great or like I'm wearing today a
fun pattern that puts me in a good mood
in the morning because love is supposed
to be fun whether you're someone else or
just yourself whether sorry whether you
love someone else or just yourself it's
usually a good time that's why me Andy's
has super comfortable and cute undies
bralettes loungewear and more and flirty
new prints for this v-day season Comfort
is sexy so get matching with someone you
love or just match with your favorite
all furball for the cutest pics anyone
has ever seen available in sizes extra
small to 4X they have something for
everybody to every booty excuse me to
fall in love with and me Andy's has a
great offer for our listeners get 20 off
your first order and free us shipping
right to your door to get 20 off your
first order free us shipping and chat
with their incredible a cheek Squad
about any questions or sizing concerns
Go to meundies.com weird that's
meandies.com
weird alright guys enjoy Ken Marino get
into it well yeah they gave us all this
water
look at those cases of water
everybody has it now I want to feel
special and and I see it on so many
podcasts these days
oh yeah thank you
yeah they're different kinds you want a
different kind
of sparkling flavored
oh yeah arguably Coca-Cola is a
different kind of water
so there's lots
you are I'm looking at your butt
I don't mind
I look at butts and I was it's also
bright yellow it looks like someone
highlighted your butt after Labor Day
but I figured it's gonna be so hot today
it's still absolutely
I'm booming you
all in here testicles spectacles
do you not know testicles testicles no
specs
practicals testicles wallet watch it's
how you cross yourself
do you know this
you start with testicles when you cross
yourself
taking so long to sit down and if I was
how long have you been doing stuff in
here
did we start yet are you I'm so glad we
have started because this is the one
that was one of my favorite
opening moments of all time
how's it so cool in here but that's not
working I mean that's not on I'm so glad
you asked oh
is it happening
I think that when you're if you're
stoned this it's almost like ASMR
[Music]
on your show
I have one when your show starts let me
know and then we'll but I'll tell you uh
based uh another joke off this which is
good although this was not originally a
joke I think it was just my hesitation
to do this because I'm frightened
and because of your reaction to my
outfit or non-reaction I just accepted
it yes I know
but I've watched your show I've watched
this podcast and I and I've and I've
I've realized that
that uh that you're you know you I mean
you lay into people oh this is your I
lay into people
you know you get people that's the real
sponsor of the show people's you know
some caca
what episode did you watch that I gave
every single one of them that would have
taken you
four years
last week felt like four years because I
watched every single episode
where would you like me to put this
because I don't I'll put it over here
just don't eclipse the liquid death with
it
okay
[Music]
um
what do we start out with this so we're
just gonna start talking now
let me ask you a question who goes two
inches above a couch and then and then
re-erects people who
go and women when they tinkle
I often do sit when I tinkle but by the
way
get this on the record it's great why
aren't we all said my daughter my
daughter to be my daughter I was peeing
this morning oh I have to do this why do
we have to stand up why do we have to
stand a podcast
I don't know why not here how about you
you may I'm letting you as the host like
Johnny Carson I'd go
it's not abandoning the bit if if I say
you may say
and you had an iced coffee already
is it cold brew let me tell you what my
daughter said
tell me she's four you want this here
she's
she's like
yes yeah
say it into the microphone I collected
TV guides normally I'm lobbed look
when I collect TV when I was younger I
collected TV TV guides and Mad magazines
and um and here and here is one of them
and so my wife is like how long are you
going to keep your TV Guide collection
in our house
did you do quotes because it is a TV
Guide collection
um
can I say something too why not it's a
podcast here's not it's gonna be I'm
gonna say something you know how we all
know that it's Frankenstein's monster
yes
yes the modern the 2022 version of that
style of joke is pointing out why did
you do air quotes that's literally what
it is that's the 2020
wait what's the 20 20 22. you still
haven't sat what is it 2022 what wait
the the explain that joke to me
[Music]
yes ending but you don't know the song
yet
is it is that a New York thing is that
Merv Griffin or something no I think
it's like the Mets or the Yankees or
something
yep meet them
I tried to sing that with somebody
oh you know the balls at the ladies with
their jugs jugs chugging it was a
different time
of course you could 1931 it was 19 this
is the mid 30s yeah 1931 is early 30s
yes early mid to late 30s or early to
late 30s early to late
I mean I mean there was a meet the match
song you live in a Frankenstein's
monster you're you
[Music]
grew up on Long Island so you grew up
telling people you live oh on Long
Island which is it's actually
Frankenstein's monster like it's one of
those what does that mean which is also
what was the other example I gave I
don't know that's what I was asking
because your wife went your TV Guide
collection she didn't and I do you did I
did I thought she really did but here's
what here I think I thought she really
was the thing I was putting the quotes
in the wrong thing I was saying my wife
said
oh here over the whole thing over the
whole thing but I couldn't I couldn't
guarantee that she said those exact
words but I could guarantee that she
said TV Guide collection so that's why
we spread out the quotes oh it was a
poll quote so I was I was pulling a part
of the quote and then I was paraphrasing
the rest of the quote as is your one how
do you paraphrase uh if we're using your
hands because I like to use them
italicized he sort of paraphrase or this
that's good which just looks like you're
putting a cat to sleep not dead
like lulling it with scratches not dead
no I just started purring when you did
that right are you a cat person
well in that situation I was the cat no
I understand
uh but I like cats sure
can I tell you something
I mean why not we're on a podcast right
I used to do Hi how are you don't
acknowledge Katie why not Katie by the
way it's virtue signaling oh Katie's a
person too blah blah blah Katie I
offered to buy some coffee
I like that that's okay but did you want
one I didn't pass it on
and guess who knew that
oh there you go wait I used to do this
just to kind of change it up
of course but that looks like you're
looking for what am I looking for
the G-Spot
I would have to kind of blend them
together and then well that's this is
you're having a three-way oh I see
there's three people involved and just
to be clear you're still a cat
tell me about what happened
to this
well I just got that for you because my
wife said uh to get to ask me how long
am I keeping my
TV Guide how long are you keeping your
TV Guide collection and she makes a
great Point what am I doing
I don't know Ken
you're a man of leisure yeah but what
the hell am I like to sit in boxes in my
house I also collected Mad Magazines
which I'm not getting rid of those yeah
those make me laugh these
these are fun they're nostalgic but I
want to give them to people who would
appreciate that so this was in your home
this was in my home what about these
bags that was uh
perfectly in the kitchen I just didn't
want to you know um have my the oils my
finger really destroy the Dick Clark
cover
I gave my friend Joda Rose a joke I
shouldn't talk about this but I said
when Dick Clark died do you think
everyone stood around his bed and went
10.
[Music]
before he died right before he died
and you can see why I gave it away yeah
it's too dark for old homes that's fine
you like it yes there's something about
him in his prime smiling at me as I told
that joke to you he liked it you think
somebody looking down on us right now
yeah or up
I don't know what he did in his personal
life well also Heaven is below us too
can we just acknowledge that it's all
around actually there's no up Ken don't
jump to the third Act of the show it's
in my Mr Turk shirt
yeah that's a great shirt thank you so
much you do wear it it's not a full bed
so the bit was so my wife and I went to
a Palm Springs
uh a party where we all had to wear what
are those uh
long kind of gown type uh graduation no
they're just I forget what they're
called but Mr Turk sells them Mr Turk is
the company that sells this so we drove
and we didn't have them
and so we went into uh Palm Springs and
then we stopped at Mr Turk and I saw
this and believe it or not everything
from the sandals
down to the I mean everything on sale
this outfit was on sale
so I said let me try that can you
believe it I can't believe it
so I said let me try that on
the guy's like yeah go ahead there's a
dressing room you don't have to you
don't have to ask me just pick it up and
try it on so I did
it fit like a glove yeah or like a shirt
and a pair of shorts and a sandals those
sandals are like somewhere between a
gladiator and Jesus but that's on a boat
can you imagine if Jesus was a gladiator
just going around he that changed this
whole kind of message yes slaughtering
people yeah I used to have a joke sorry
I'm gonna just tell you jokes that I
think listen that's Kenny what you do
for a living I also want to know what
what episode you saw where I gave
someone Kaka But Here Comes the bet I
won't forget you don't give people kakai
you just you know you uh you have fun
with everybody the Razzle Dazzle give a
little Razzle all from a loving space
what I listen before this is the story
so when you asked me to do this I I was
like oh God I gotta like I gotta think
of it well because I was with Ben right
and Ben's like Sonic yeah Ben Schwartz
and he and Sonic the Hedgehog Ben Sonic
the Hedgehog Schwartz no the last name's
gone it's gone it's in his contract
really yep and for no reason when I was
talking to Ben Sonic the Hedgehog thank
you uh you're welcome
uh I went and listened to the one the
several that you've done with him with
Benny Schwartz yes and then I just went
down the rabbit hole of listening to a
number of other ones the Sonic hole um
no not the Sonic hole he's gone now I'm
just listening to you and I went you
know kind of and as okay so you heard
did you listen to the whole first Ben
Schwartz episode the non-zoom one from
many years ago I listened to some of
that one I mean you know you these are
these are these are two hours these are
chunky donkeys chunky donkeys these are
chunky donkeys even if you dip them in
your coffee it's still a meal it's still
a meal but I listen but what I remember
is a lot of stuff about
um video games with Ben so I think that
might have been the second one
that sounds about right but what were we
talking about well look all I'm going to
say is one of the hardest times I've
ever laughed is the first time Ben did
it and I'm not even going to tell but
let's just say I told a story where I
looked like a fool and we did the story
again but he improvised it so it went my
way oh and I sang spontaneously without
any thought and I Will Always Love You
Whitney Houston style sure immediately
but I meant it like he healed me like
like a story where I was embarrassed he
flipped it and redid it and it like it
was like therapy
but he's very good at that he is very
good at that yeah and you know what this
is actually uh
Tony Robbins who I I always say this
when I bring him up I don't know where
he is in the public the the Giant
yeah he lives at the top gigantic
Blockhead it's not it's only gigantic to
us to him it's a normal head he looks
normal all these people with their tiny
hands all these people with their tiny
heads yeah yeah I don't understand it
picks up a horse and takes a bite that's
right wow he thought it was chocolate he
thought it was a chocolate
brownies somewhere near Easter then
blood just gushes out and it's a
horrible surprise every time that it was
actually and it starts it does it over
and over again this is something that he
does when will I learn and then he puts
it down Tony don't put it down bite its
head off it is it is whipping and naying
debt
so he just lets him suffer as he eats
them do I have something in my tooth no
I just wanted to touch my teeth in the
way that some people might touch their
chin okay do I have something on my chin
he says when something traumatic happens
to you you should replay it in your mind
I've done this replay it in your mind uh
faster as a cartoon like funny like have
it Go bigger like if your boss yells at
you and it freaks you out do it faster
and funnier just picture your boss
coming in but he's a cartoon
and just do it over and over and this is
kind of what we're doing with movies and
TV as we're watching other people
process the same problems and feelings
that we have but for some reason it
helps our brain make sense of reality
and give a little distance a little
perspective so he says just like cut cut
the middleman and just just make your
own movie in your head and make it and
make it faster and funnier because
that's a note you always give in common
hey guys that was great a little faster
funny yeah faster funny faster and
bigger and bigger don't do it Ken Moreno
Rob wriggle wait a second don't don't
give me that sleepy time that's the
thing I'm talking about kind of like why
did we even pull up wait a second see
this is what I'm talking about why did
we even I wouldn't even use the bathroom
this is the ribbing this is what I'm
talking about oh this is what I mean I
think it was
I just realized I thought I was putting
down Rob Riggle but you were like he's
where the action is
well you were saying
you're saying make it bigger and faster
and funnier so it's just bigger but we
were pairing it up with faster and fun
just bigger we were pairing it up with
faster barely touching barely touchy
are we doing a little energy yeah you
feel it
you're better than Rob Riggle yeah
I'm not better than right I didn't say
anything
I heard that it was that through the
energy my eyes were closed so
um Robbie's on the mind because Rob's
the best he's the best I've been wanting
to have him on the Pod for about a
decade now you're not gonna get him well
that's why
I'm doubling down
it's not happening it's not happening so
this isn't there this is called [__] you
rob Rex no no knock it off stop it but
I'm not ribbing you only yes sanding
that that you wanted a gentle ribbing
where were we I like beloved do you have
on your thing Be Love and You Got The
Joker hugging Batman did you do that
whose painting is that I did paint that
you painted that yeah I love it you do I
do you're a sweetie you're a sweetie
your secret sweetie I mean that's not
it's not a secret you're just a sweet
man I mean I'm just I'm just a you know
a sweetie you're here to love
it's all about love right
well what I like about bee love is that
it being nice I'm all for being nice and
being polite he's talking about a
sticker I have my treadmill used to be
here and I'd look at be love and
um it's just a it's a reminder that love
is actually like a state and and you
know what I love about it it's actually
the state that emerges when you when you
turn everything off
like if you can settle down your mind if
I could stop doing riffs about Rob
Riggle and if I could stop wondering how
I look on camera or wondering what I'm
going to say next or whatever it might
be and just like ease into what's
happening into the moment into reality I
noticed that my natural state actually
is love doesn't mean I like everything
but like I can find the spacious bright
place that's interesting where
everyone's welcome I agree even the
stuff I don't like
for example
[Music]
well uh my father doesn't listen to me
enough but if I'm in love
there's my dad being my dad it's okay
right that's his but I've settled down
I've I've turned off all the voices that
go my father shouldn't turned on
judgment I turned off judgment that's a
great way to put it and I just and I'm
just loving everything that is including
the things that I don't want and just
kind of you ever have that where like
reality sort of feels like a dream and
some fan comes up to you know like a
little party
but you're just like look look at the
look at this guy he's spitting on me you
know but like you can find a dream like
appreciation for the absurdity of
whatever's going on okay so I'm really
getting this from Byron Katie who wrote
loving what is which is an Incredible
Book highly recommend when you can love
what is and drop a lot of your suffering
is coming from wishing something was
different like I wish my father would
listen to me which by the way my dad
does listen to me from time to time so
this is just a good example so wanting
people to change the way they yeah
there's like yes well consider it what
is something oh we don't have to do you
but this is what Katie would say I say
my father should listen to me more she
would say is that true and I would be
like yeah I mean like what am I basing
that on like like where am I getting the
idea that he should that I am in control
of how much people should how much you
should listen to me right how much
anybody like I should dictate like you
should only care me Captain right even
your own thoughts your own feelings move
them aside here I come or I need my
father to listen to me more is that true
because here I am doing fine moving
around feeling sometimes feeling sad
that's also okay well let me ask you
something when your father does listen
to you you recognize that I mean when
that happens well there's got to be a
moment where your dad takes something in
that you see for sure yeah and so when
that happens do you feel differently
different differently yeah differently
feel differently yeah do you sorry you
got me stuck on adverbs
that's a great question if when the
moments that I've had with my father
have like deep connection where like
he's really you're like oh finally he
listened to me so you're comparing when
he doesn't listen to you to something
right why not I mean I would assume that
you when you say my father doesn't
listen to me yeah you're comparing it to
the moments where you feel like he did
he did and that's that's brilliant is
that right yeah I think that's really
interesting and so what are those
moments and and are they far and few
between or do they exist at all or have
you made up a version of what it would
be like for him to listen to you anymore
I want to listen to you how you are
because like I called home on Sunday and
I got my dad and we facetimed and I was
talking to Val my wife about it later
and I was like my dad I got my dad in a
great mood like I got him in one of
those moods where he was he just had
more RAM he had more energy to spare
more uh more space in his mind for me
and for what we were saying so I got
like this Primo dad and then the belief
that causes suffering later is I want
that Dad all the time right but that's
not fair because I'm not you're not
exactly I mean it was what you were
saying to Ben just to go back to one of
the things where you were like you guys
were talking about uh you were saying be
my uh you know would you want to hang
out with me when I'm not on or doing
like my show Persona or some version
yeah right where you were like
and questioning do
would people want to hang out with me
when I'm not just doing bits or being
funny like when I have a bad day or um
yeah right exactly and you're you're you
listen perfectly because really what I'm
saying in that is like oh God am I like
my father that I have big ups and then
like maybe I'll be like I'll have days
where I'm just like nobody yeah sure you
feel that way too of course of course
and how are you with sharing less than
Sterling obviously all of the Ken's are
Sterling but when you feel less than
Sterling do you hide do you Retreat or
or can you share that with your wife
with your kids yeah I mean sometimes I'm
not even aware of it and sometimes it
comes out in ways where
um my wife will for example just just
since she brought up my wife
you know she's like whoa you know like
like I'll I'll be I'll have it I'll be
short I'll be yeah I'll be I won't be
patient or I'll
but I but I and she might point it out
or I might recognize it right afterwards
and I think I have the wherewithal to
kind of be like sorry about that that
was because I'm just
dealing with X Y and Z yeah
um can I tell you the one I use the most
with Val it's it's really helped my life
immensely we'll be right back mid-rolls
I'm just kidding is
um I'm sorry I was just embarrassed like
I'll I'll catch myself
feeling inadequate or feeling like
ill-prepared for some sort of situation
and then I'll be short or not as warm as
I'd like to be to Val and almost always
when I look to the feeling that sort of
pushed the shortness off the shelf like
yeah pushed it into reality yeah the
feeling was
I'm I'm not ready I'm I'm scared
everyone's gonna see that I'm a clammy
wet sweaty boy with braces you know that
that boy that we hit pause on yeah there
were like I'll speak for myself that I'm
afraid people are going to discover
that's that's who I still am like he's
still in there so like a lack of like a
lack of
confidence in those moments it's like a
a fear of being exposed yeah I suppose
don't you feel like everybody though
ultimately every who who the only person
who well I was going to say the only
people who don't feel that fear of being
exposed or narcissist but those are the
people who feel it fear it the most
right I wonder but isn't that the whole
thing that narcissistic they're not
they're not people who aren't aware of
that there is a deep thing of like I'm
going to be exposed so I'm going to
Triple down to Triple down on that which
is exactly what you know [__] ex you
know president well that's that was my
question for you I when I tried to find
compassion for Trump somebody I I
disagree with obviously I wondered in
the morning and I'm putting this
question to you
when he puts his socks on and he's kind
of
resuming his personality you know those
feelings in the morning where I feel
that Pete holmesiness kind of coming
back in and I've done a lot of work to
love myself I've done a lot of work to
soften myself believe it or not as I'm
flapping around and talking too much and
all this stuff but this is effort right
but like I don't mind when Pete resumes
control of me I like beat and I work on
Pete right but there are some mornings
where I'm like oh God
it's just too much and my question is
does Trump in the Oval Office in the in
the the bedroom office anymore no I know
but but when he was I'm thinking of like
that was when it was the most necessary
to always be the trumpiest Trump you
could ever Trump when he put on the Sock
City ever just quietly in the dark
question his just go like
God
like just that
it's a good question I think it's an
important question
I don't think he has the awareness of it
I think he's that's a very into yeah
yeah who he is that and and worldview
world view that that it
that that it doesn't come into play
anymore I think that's interesting and
that goes back to I think it's static
and then he's clicked in and he doesn't
he never questions his that's what we're
talking about here the moment when you
question and Jason Alexander just did a
part of just came out and he was saying
to have the courage to look in the
mirror and like at the ugliness at your
own pettiness your own greed your own
shallowness anger whatever it might be
rage you have to you have to be brave to
look at that so you're I I would agree
with you you don't think there's a
moment you never see never he's never
gone up to anybody and been like I'm so
sorry I was um
I was um I was thinking about something
else and I snapped at you or you know
what I mean like you're like you you
said like I'm so I'm so sorry I was that
was me I was like I was scared or did I
talked to you for a second I'm just
having a big day it was just I got 20
things on my mind and I I didn't even
mean it for you did not treat you
properly there no they have never in it
a million years would he do that but you
and I have done that right right we've
gone up to people we care about and said
sorry about that that was [__] up
about my part so father Greg Boyle who
just did this podcast just before Jason
he talked about how whenever he does
he's a prison chaplain sometimes and he
says that the guards always say the same
thing which is I don't I'd be nicer to
the inmates but I don't want them to
mistake my kindness for weakness I think
there's a similar thing going on with
Trump type folks if I said
I'm sorry yeah I was thinking about my
big red tie right right
yeah they think that it that we would
take that as weakness but father Greg
makes this incredible point where he
goes the only once you see reality once
you see the big picture what's going on
here you recognize that the only
strength is kindness that's actual
strength
I would because I I thought you were
going to say it's kindness but the only
strength is
admitting
right the only strength is being like I
don't know it all I'm I'm figuring it
out I just move my head like I'm
swirling a delicious wine in my I was
like kind of wine do you like I used to
love sake actually which is a rice wine
I just didn't want you to think that I
didn't know that it wasn't lined no no I
mean I I for the moment until you
correct until you're not corrected yeah
yeah but it's anticipated I don't know
what to do do I wait until after the
podcast to tell him that sake is not it
is though but it is but it is it's a
rice one uh it's a rice wine it's a
beautiful rice wine we have the best
rice
wine I don't know why I said that about
sake I don't I don't even really care
for it he won't stop apologizing I
actually love soccer I I didn't mean
which by the way is what uh Taiko Taiko
watiti and Reese what is it taika [__] I
always don't say Tiger but then I do say
is uh is just that is going like I like
you I like your little yellow [__] not
not that it's little it's not little if
it's just right not that I'm looking at
the curves of your arm nothing I mean
you do have curves of your arm you must
work out maybe you do get it from
picking up your kids I'm not thinking
about you picking up your kids I mean
maybe you do wait I don't want to say
your impression of him or is this this
is a style
he did something like this no this is
the essence the essence of a very uh uh
new zealandy sort of flavor of Comedy is
the opposite of trump yes right
constantly just we're like correcting
look at that dumb shirt is Trump he's
like I like those shorts unless they're
meant to be a long pen if that's what
you consider a long pant to be and then
right there constantly correct yeah
correct we think that is funny because
it's so weak but I didn't mean the
burgundy in my mouth it was burgundy was
just appreciating that you're saying
there's we need a new model for strength
which is
I say to my daughter all the time even
though she's she's only four I'll be
like yeah Dad I made a mistake I was
wrong like I got overwhelmed sometimes
when she's screaming I go like baby this
is this is really freaking me like I'll
just tell her right instead of you know
throwing down the gauntlet or like
trying to do an impression of what uh
what a powerful man or dad is supposed
to do how old's your daughter she's four
she's four she'll be four this month you
wanna
come to the party I mean I was hoping to
get some sort of an invitation to the
birthday party I for entertainment I can
juggle I can ride a unicycle I can I
give you a great clue
have you ever done any cleaning
um I have uh I'm sure I had to take it
well the truth is is uh in high school
well when I was younger you know before
the uh the tick tocks and the internet
and all that stuff you had to just
figure out stuff to to to
um throw on a VHS yeah to kind of well
before before that or not right when I
was starting but we didn't have it right
away we didn't have the VHS I'm a little
older than you said I taught myself how
to I bought a book and taught myself how
to juggle oh from a book from a book
what does the book say no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no it was
like the dummies guide to juggling and
then I I was like I'm going to get a
unicycle and I'm going to teach myself
how to unisex so I guess I had some sort
of want to be in the circus or a clown
yes
um and then
um in high school
somebody hired me to come to their party
and be a clown one time then I juggled
and that was so yeah I guess I was a
clown I was a clown
you in high school you juggle everyone
collaps and then you realize you have
nothing else you go back to the book
squirting flowers
I can't just do can you do it with a
regular flower does anyone have a flower
I juggled I wrote a unicycle for you
know 30 seconds and then I uh went over
to the food and I ate it and I left
that's what you do orgy rules yeah
Georgie rules yeah do your thing hit the
buffet then leave yeah yeah yeah but you
said
I'm hard of hearing did you say orgy
rolls I I said orgy rules
orgy rolls are the cinnamon buns at the
buffet in an orange
they love anything that has a body I was
hoping for some sun yes cinnamon buns no
buns always buns never rolls cinnamon
buns and they love uh foot lungs
obviously
yep yep cantaloupes melons and melons of
any kind again you can't throw a condom
without hitting a melon
um what uh what else are we talking
about
they only have foods that are body parts
we don't need to worry ourselves
everyone can think of their own at home
but uh
kiwis always in pairs
um oh pears pears sure
um tell me what what you sounded like
you were about to say heavy cream huh
what
what was I gonna be cream
heavy creamsicles I don't know I was
trying to think of something just heavy
cream was fine you think I didn't like
heavy cream well you did a little fart
and then the little fart was like
there's so much laughter coming up that
a fart came out that I chose to Delight
you the way I had been delighted to turn
it into a tiny wet one
um Be Love Tell Me a Memory you have and
I want you to love it of when you were
when you were putting it together oh
that little Kenny Marine yeah on Long
Island yes Frankenstein's monster
is Long Island Frankenstein's monster no
no no correcting people
I'm I I grew up on Long Island not in
Long Island is is
similar to correcting it wasn't
Frankenstein it was Frankenstein's
monster oh yeah so here's a question oh
so this is the you were ribbing somebody
for saying Mario instead of Mario yeah
yeah yeah I believe it was Ben that's
right Mario yeah he said Mario what do
you say I bet he's from the tri-state
area me too and I say Mario Mario and my
kids and my wife Mary oh correct me
because it sounds like a woman whose
last name is you know honestly who cares
why can't we like what here's my
question about them about Mario not
about Mario but about like saying stuff
everybody says stuff a little
differently and people from Boston I
mean their whole thing is off it's
that's just nuts it's goofy troopy but
it's but you know it is it is what it is
but it is right so why
I this is a question and it's not I
don't mean to like
come at you but why did why did you
need to correct him
uh something to talk about I suppose
that's it that's your question I was so
hoping you were going to say why do
people feel the need to correct well I
mean in general I mean I'm using you as
an example but like why do people feel
the need to correct well I think you
could step it back to basic tribalism
and identity my group says Mario you say
Mario right I say it wrong
I'm not even saying no but I do say it
wrong but you don't but like for example
I I used to say check this out I used to
say 300 million people that say Mary I
used to say like it was when people say
library library is wrong of course but
some people say it a lot of people on
Long Island say it I don't say it that
way but you know but I've for the
longest time and I never thought about
it and you're gonna make fun of me I am
not I promise and then somebody
corrected me and I felt like a fool
right I say I would say Let Me Tell You
souvenir what is it I would say
[Laughter]
I would say
souvenir
[Music]
and and I'm not making fun of you I'm
dividing I'm delighting that you would
think and I got Sylvan here it's and and
so I was corrected and I was like it's
souvenir
and and they're like yeah it's still
it's souvenir and I'm like all right
well what's the difference
and then like because one is correct and
one isn't but like I just then all of a
sudden I was like on the defensive
because of something that I was never
even aware of and I felt then I made
Then I then I felt bad well that was a
power trip for the person who corrected
you for sure
there's a gentle way to do it it sounds
like they did it they did it pretty
gently oh really but but still I was I
got I felt embarrassed
and the truth is
but the truth is is like throughout life
we all miss classes on some something
you right there we all miss no no I mean
specific but like we yeah just sometimes
we miss out on [__] and we forget we
don't we don't we don't hear it
correctly and then we say it that way
for about a time I said Channel instead
of Channel until I was 25 years old I
did my first wife
I don't know if she's alive or dead I
was gonna go may she rest
are you saying channel so God love her
she helped me and she did it gently I
used to say change she changed the
channel I want to get a silver near okay
so here's it here's the other thing I
was on a show I was shooting a show in
here and Mike and I was a guest on the
show and I my the ice I said the word I
don't even know if it was I don't think
it was in the script but it might have
been a line in the script and I said uh
uh d-o-n-k-e-y
donkey
I said donkey donkey
what did you say
it's donkey
donkey
donkey donkey this is like when you go
on Google and you click pronounce donkey
donkey
and I I'm not hearing it I said
some people say it with like a u like a
donkey donkey donkey donkey what do you
say well now I'm confused because I
believe I said donkey and she was like
it's donkey and she made fun of me okay
that person was she chewing on a strand
of wheat but maybe I said donkey and she
was like it's donkey
I I think I said maybe donkey I think I
said donkey and she said
and she said it's donkey
and I was like okay and I was a guest on
the show and I felt terrible okay and I
was embarrassed
and I didn't I you know and I you know
what Pete I didn't appreciate it
because I'm here I'm not perfect no I'm
human yeah and I missed that that day
you donkey day all right so whoever said
it to me said it the wrong way and so
then I said it the wrong way and I
didn't need to be corrected on whatever
the hell the UPN show was
it was a up engine I don't know CW Maybe
those are sixes right there one of those
that's six shows I know it was one of
those shows well okay Aaron Sorkin oh
here we go here
you good friend if you is he no I mean
I've worked for him okay acquaintance
what not a good friend
acquaintance
I've played poker with him he's a very
nice guy
I did his play right out of college
which one A Few Good Men oh I toured the
so it was on Broadway and then when I
graduated college
it was uh starting the tour
of A Few Good Men uh six-month tour and
we toured all over the country and I met
him then and then I met him a couple
times since very nice guy wow but um but
you were in a Few Good Men in the the
touring production
yes and was that remarkable yeah it was
great who were you were you the tea
Crews no i i understudied two of the you
know two of the parts and so I was a guy
who most nights just walked on stage and
went
and moved the furniture around okay and
then uh I got to understudy uh Lance
corporal Dawson the the one guy on trial
and then one time I had I
um
uh uh the part that
it was smaller in the movie but no Wiley
played in the movie
I don't remember the character's name
this is a long time ago I don't remember
much anyway you're going to say
something about Aaron Sorkin I was
all I know is Santiago and Tom Cruise
and Jack Nicholson and Kevin Bacon and
Demi Moore those those are the only ones
you know
um but Santiago is the character's name
Santiago is the one who's murdered and
yeah and then everybody else were the
actors who played the characters
or you think Santiago was actually
murdered and then they made a movie no
but you said all I remember was Santiago
and then and then you're like Jack
Nicholson Tom Cruise Demi Moore
more those aren't cat those are those
right Santiago doesn't know those guys
they you're right Santiago
and Diego what if I did know who played
Santiago Bert halbron who did play
Santiago it's a small part yeah but
sometimes those small parts that's the
first part for like the at the next big
thing like Tom Cruise in uh in uh in
Taps okay
in one of those early movies
what Kevin Smith All the Right Moves
well
let's just say it has a home at the
buffet you know what I mean is it All
the Right Moves where do we see Tom
Cruise's dingo he Kevin said you see
full frontal bang There It Is I'd see
the Taps Are All the Right Moves can we
find is there any way to yeah Katie has
the internet
and what is this internet well I'm all
I'm familiar with is a book about
juggling and
and teaching myself how to ride my
unicycle on my on my driveway what
there's a internet what does that do
I thought of you in the 80s perched up
on a unicycle just kind of learning it
yeah in your driveway putting doing it
again I mean look to the point where I
had like saddle swords of course you did
what else do you do during the day you
just do you find things to I worry a
little bit about the lack of boredom my
daughter said she was bored for the
first time in her life
that's good that's pretty good she made
it to four but she and and all of her
feelings are welcome but I was like oh
my God yeah I mean she's got a lot of
stimuli a lot of like flowers like my my
kids are myself unicycles for her my
son's 15 my daughter's 13 and it's yeah
it's hard to I guess their their boredom
is to just like you know get into the
phone and just do the thing but I I I do
wish that there was times that they were
bored and just weren't just and didn't
have that and just wrote it out yeah
that's why you have to get like a cabin
but they sometimes like they'll do art
or like they'll paint or they'll you
know
um you know work out or they'll do
something to kind of they're working out
all the sun is yeah 13 15. oh he's the
15. yeah he's taller than me at this
point when do you this is like you're in
your John Hamm
you're full ham
I don't know what that means deal with
it
what does that mean I'm saying you look
better now to prepare
I love party down I just I almost as a
new Season's coming out
the first quarter of next month but um
that's great I'll edit all of that out
but I thought I would watch I typed in
best of Kenmore right I'll edit all that
out that's a joke I I type an
investigator you know the first thing
that came up was party down clips of you
and I watch them this is how you
researched this is part of the this is
part of your research I also read your
Wikipedia page okay and personal life
was wanting so let's add to it
personal life was it was like written by
a drone it was like Ken Moreno is
married with two children I was like how
often do you go in and delete that 19th
again he one time saw Tony Robbins pick
up a horse that he thought was chocolate
I'm gonna have to imagine this is a
cartoon later because it's gushing
oh God horses so much blood it's a lot
of blood you don't think about when
you're on a horse
that's all I think about riding like a
giant uh like uh exactly like a sack of
blood it's like a horse skinned bag of
yeah you see all those veins in their in
their back legs all I'm thinking about
is all that blood just coursing through
their veins and I hope Tony Robbins
isn't nearby
they're huge
donkey dogs
I watched you on party down and which
I've seen through many times love it uh
thank you so much you're wonderful on it
and I thought Jesus Christ uh camerino
is in his John Hamm you look better now
than you did that how long ago was that
12 years ago who looks better than they
did 12 years ago candy Marine John Hamm
well J ham
that's that's where we got the you're in
your full John him yeah yeah so yeah and
now your son's working out
what a Segway
are the marinos
are they uh
question what I'm wondering what changed
what what have you done in your life
people like these types of things I feel
like you figured something out
about my looks about my physical yeah it
seems like you found a nice cruising
altitude your physicality has part to do
with that but what have you figured out
in the past 12 years that that well
balanced your life
that balanced my life and your
physicality let's get Petty Well you
aren't talking about John Hamm when you
said I'm all John hammed you weren't
talking about my life that's right but
then it seemed like you prickled a
little bit at the physical uh Wellness
section of this yeah I want you to so
but I want to know I want to be clear on
the question because I'll answer either
how did you babe it up so hard dude
I don't know what that you know what it
means what I what I will say is
Colonel Santiago I thought he was a
colonel
Colonel Jessup that's uh uh uh uh Jack
Nicholson's name oh all right Colonel
you know he improvised you can't handle
the truth no he didn't
that was a riff
um
the what I found was in my 20s when I
was living in New York and I was doing
the state and
um uh uh there was a lot of
um excessive eating and drinking and
hanging out and debauchery I heard you
befriended people by walking around with
a milk crate filled with liquor
that who told you that wikipedia.com
that's not true it's not true I mean
well I mean it is true did Wikipedia
tell you that it's on Wikipedia yeah yes
that is true so there was some bad
behavior
well I'm just saying that the so then in
my 30s I slowed down on that a little
bit and then in my 40s I slowed down on
it even more and so I it all evened out
you're saying your Vice was was chugging
the rug no no I'm saying that you're
asking why yeah what did you figure out
what I figured out is is um if you
really get puffy in your 20s and then
you get less puffy in your 30s and then
you get less puffy in your 40s and then
even less puffy in your 50s you'll look
sort of the same the whole way through
that's so funny because aging is the
same as drinking basically I'm I'm I I
just I
touch myself up in my 20s and 30s yeah
so I could look
better in my 40s and 50s like I know
you're kidding but that is so [__]
funny I know you're getting butt that is
I mean that is
it's like you could write a book
not bad am I kidding like like
look like [__] in your 20s so that when
you cool it right you can look like you
did in your 20s right but you'll always
look like the same pretty good [__]
that's right
pretty good [__] by Ken Marino that's it
there you go that's pretty good nuts so
was that your advice of choice what
chugging the rug
no I mean you know uh my advice of
choice was was
um rice wine just trying to yeah for a
rice wine no I just I don't know if I
had advice of choice I
I enjoyed my 20s being a single or you
know being a young
individual living in Manhattan hanging
out with a bunch of my friends
um
I I enjoyed that time
[Laughter]
for some reason that felt so guarded
that it made me feel bad for asking you
no I mean there's no SP there's nothing
specific like it's not like I'm like oh
you know I went crazy and I didn't go
nuts no you just consistently I ate
whatever uh Manhattan had to offer I
went to the bars that I was uh able to
go to in my 20s because I was no longer
underage and uh that's the that's that
you know that's what you do what about
uh weed weed smoking you do that
um I did I did back then
um
and now now that it's like uh legal I
got so excited about it and I would go
to the the places and
um buy stuff and then I'm like I don't
I don't have the time with kids and I'm
like I'm also it's just not it's not
something I particularly uh crave or
want
like I I guess I enjoyed I don't even
know if I enjoyed it back then I just
you did it and then you know it's fun
for like movies to go see movies I don't
know I mean you know I don't know I love
I love parent Ken that I was like you
ever do PCP
I know my son is 15 he's doing a dead
lift right now you ever see a ghost
have I ever seen a ghost or well
you're thinking about it well what's the
ore or have you ever experienced
anything that you can't explain like
something like super weird
where you're like well that defies the
laws of reason
see
would it was it revisionist history like
when you when you somebody you think
something happened but it really is like
maybe something that happened to your
parents or your friend that's I feel
like
when I was a kid
in our home apparently either I saw it
or somebody saw a ghost at the top of
the stairs
but I don't really recall and it didn't
affect me too deeply
um I do
a story in a capsule it's the least
reliable it started with like you know
revisionist history
here's the thing Pete I don't remember
much okay
um uh it's all super
foggy
all of it
um except for like little moments I you
know like there are people who remember
everything right yes all through their
life and it's like it they lit they can
call back every single moment Joe the
truglio is a person uh do you know Joe
have you ever met Joe or done him uh
interview him on the show he can kind of
break down every moment
I can't my wife also Eric oyama
um is somebody who can kind of be like
this is what happened this is what
happened he like I'm just it's all a big
fog to me I understand I'm the same way
but I think and I think it has to do
with approaching
surviving as an actor
in this town or just in this industry it
sort of bled over into my just personal
life or my existence of who I am
for better for worse meaning that
um you have so much rejection in in this
town right and over the years especially
early on a lot of like no's
and the way to
move forward is to let it go right to
forget about it right I've been with you
since you started I I had a sense this
is where you're going and I feel very
strong right so so in order to do that
you have to have a certain you have to
create a certain mindset for yourself to
be like that happened
that negative thing happened or that
experience happened negative or positive
but I didn't get the job
um I'm gonna let that go yes and I'm
gonna forget about it I'm not going I'm
going I'll try to remember things that
will help me moving forward
um little pieces of it but ultimately I
cannot remember it otherwise it will
destroy me you're the guy from Memento
and you're just writing the helpful bits
like
learn your lines for the audition that's
or whatever but you're not writing they
all laughed in my face right or whatever
because it doesn't serve you it doesn't
serve and there's too much static
negativity the odds are so in
insurmountable now I'm yeah
right uh
insurmountable see we all have it Kenny
you're not you're not you're that's not
a souvenir come on anyway look let's not
let's stay on point because this is good
this is interesting this is interesting
or maybe maybe it's just interesting to
you and I I don't know one of your
techniques for show business is take
what's useful and leave the rest because
you've got to forget not even just leave
it forget it like delete it delete it
from your brain right yes so over the
course and so it definitely affected
um not even talking about personal life
yet it affected
how I would approach good news
in the industry which would be tell me I
gotta I got the job the big job you're
going to be in the reboot of uh Star
Wars A New Hope oh that's great
right yeah that so I so I somehow you've
even I've evened it out like I've been
causing you something because I wouldn't
get upset about the bed let me give you
this something else but you're not gonna
be in the reboot of Return of the Jedi
okay
I knew it you Salty Dog so so all of a
sudden the way I was able to survive
here and not here in this room but in
this town
was to not have high highs and low lows
that's what uh Conan he has a he used to
wear it I don't know if he still does it
he has a bracelet that says
um steady bass hum or low base hum or
something he was like I don't want highs
and lows I just want a steady
like just a normal yeah even experience
well I want to get back to that
but to
finish my point is what happened was in
in using that technique or whatever it
is
it bled into my
personal life and I that just my in this
is how I think of it and this is why I
don't remember [__] is is I just
I just I live I experience the thing and
then it just sort of goes away and
somehow it infected my personal kind of
memory as opposed to just kind of the
approach to kind of surviving in this
town does that make sense yeah for sure
to the Conan point you made oh I have a
follow-up on that oh is that ever not I
won't forget the Conan thing is that
ever not helpful
professionally or personally personally
I'm terrible personally yeah that's what
I'd like to hear about it's it's it
that's what we're talking about I was
like I don't you ask me questions about
like you ever see a ghost yeah and I'm
like I think maybe I don't remember I
don't you know like unless I saw it like
on my walk here for my car right I don't
but like you run into people and you
don't know how you met them does that
happen constantly
yes all the time I I was just in
Montreal and I was talking to Val and I
was like have you ever been
to Montreal with me I couldn't remember
and the answer is the answer was yes
yeah if she wasn't upset about it
because she knows how my mind works but
she was like Yeah remember and she
reminds me but I need that help to find
the breadcrumbs and then I remember but
like it's super important that people
that I love know that one of the ways I
love people is not remembering
everything we've ever done together no
it's showing your love for them in the
moment that's right and I yeah so that
is yeah for sure I take pictures not
even for posting just to remember stuff
I take pictures and then I go back and
I'm like holy [__] we went to my family
went to France like I'm like
if I didn't look at those pictures it's
it like it would have come back in some
sort of conversation if somebody talked
about France but like you know it was
not it wasn't even in there
until I saw pictures then I was like
this wave of like yes
[__] so the one of the things I love
about tricky download he's a thousand
pictures a thousand pictures that you
can take on your phone like all the time
yeah I try to do it all the time because
it really does help me remember yeah
we're the people they made for seven
years for what's that we're the people
they made souvenirs for that's right
um can I just change the trajectory of
that yeah uh AC because it's because I
don't know if you've noticed I have some
holes in my shirt how do we do it
uh swing
I think swing is what it's doing now
if you
if I hit this this is a good TV right
here this is great there we go how's
that is that right on you no that's over
here that's great okay we did it
um I couldn't relay more all right so so
so you the Conan thing right you you
don't want High highs and low lows I can
I to reload you back into that topic I
just got a call
now just now
actually
my manager's assistant has figured out
that my phone's always on do not disturb
so they just call me twice I was like
it's probably Val I gotta go something's
wrong with the baby and I just see my
management company and I'm like I know
it's just
um they want to know if at the orgy you
want melons there's two things there's
three things now three questions one one
why are they do why tell them stop tell
them to stop doing that I never knew
that existed on the phone and three
do are they really leaving you messages
about the melons and the orgy I'm sure
that whatever it is
is not important is not super important
meaning
I'm doing a podcast which they know you
do they they don't know when I'm doing
it but here it is
I can I can get back one of my favorite
Chance the Rapper lyrics my lawyer says
it's urgent I'm gonna call him in an
hour that's one of my favorite lines
wait say that again my lawyer says it's
urgent I'm a column in an hour
I just love that chance has so many
lyrics that are just about like uh the
industry can't stop me I don't take
seriously what all of you people take
seriously I'm just having fun I'm just
making art like [__] off and I listen to
it and I'm just like how did all of this
fun of Show Business get turned into
like Ken we need to know are you
bringing a plus one to the SAG Awards
like
how did we get from you meeting David
Wayne on your first day at NYU
Wikipedia to that
that is I love you you have you answered
my question the greatest lesson you've
learned about Show Business which is
burn it all to the ground the moment
it's done yeah which I'm gonna actually
maybe over flatter and say that's in the
dead ching and say do your work and be
done with it the only way to Serenity
that's that's a great great line so
there you are being wise
um what is your greatest lesson that you
would oh is the day
uh is there a book The Dao of Pooh yes
is it about that I bet it's about how
the lessons of Winnie the Pooh are very
Taoist yeah right yeah yeah and I think
there's a lot of like Dao and then they
did Zen and the Art of Motorcycle
Maintenance right right right right but
they're all kind of like
be like inside of the Holy Bible you're
like the holy cookbook
pardon the interruption friends this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at the perfect Gene which I've been
wearing on tour all week you know why
because I'm always wearing the perfect
Jean because they're the perfect pant I
don't understand how it's 20 23 and
people are still walking around in
uncomfortable pants it used to be the
only option if you wanted something
stretchy uh you had to wear like what
linen or uh yoga pants I can't pull that
off I'm not sting it looks stupid so
enter the perfect Gene which is not only
the best fitting pair of pants that I
own it is also the best looking pair of
pants I own I would put them and I have
put them against designer jeans weird
custom jeans that I bought at some
strange denim company screw that the
perfect Gene looks way better and feels
way way better than any other pair of
pants I've ever spent way too much money
on and they're not that expensive
they're not expensive at all in fact
they're the best pants I've ever owned I
haven't taken them off since they
arrived I just rotate between my Blues
my dark Blues my grays and my blacks I
have four or five pairs of perfect jeans
and that is it because I found my
perfect pant and I'm Not Looking Back
what's the secret there's Soviet woven
Soven into it two percent spandex 2.5
round for extra comfort and movement
that your man Parts require that's right
this Jean stretches so you're not saying
crushed thereby providing the only true
home for your bone they're super soft
you might even forget that you're
wearing pants they're so soft they're
clinically proven I can't say that they
are softer than a baby's butt in my
opinion that's anecdotal softer than a
baby's butt and best of all they're not
khakis [__] your khakis and spare your
nuts the perfect Gene for the Perfectly
Imperfect men just 60 bucks
60 bucks when you use promo code weirdo
at checkout liberate your lower limbs
with the one and only perfect Gene
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a big old
hunk and eggplant the perfect Gene has
you covered take a peek at
www.theperfectgene.nyc that's the
perfect j-e-a-n dot NYC news code weirdo
for 25 off at checkout do your lower
half a favor look good and feel good and
show your support of this show we're
also brought To Us by our friend a total
Game Changer ritual multivitamins and
pro pre and post-biotics every podcast
has a pooper that's why we invited you
yeah we're talking about poop with
rituals symbiotic plus a three-in-one
clinically proven Prebiotic probiotic
and post-biotic designed to help support
a balanced microbiome we are spilling
the beans and eating them too that means
there's no more shame in your gut game
you guys know we talk a lot about gut
health on this show it has a lot to do
with your well-being your overall
feeling of Wellness as well as there's
more and more studies coming out that
your your stomach your gut is basically
like another brain you have to take care
of it and so much of our soil and our
food is just devoid of the things it
used to have in it and we need to
supplement not only do I take rituals
multivitamin for men every single day
and when I went to the doctor they told
me my vitamins were off the chart and as
a mostly vegan person that is an
incredible feat indeed I start every day
with this three in one Prebiotic
postbiotic and probiotic that has two of
the world's most clinically studied
probiotic strains to support the relief
of mild and occasional digestive
discomforts like bloating gas and
diarrhea let's just say it it's helping
with bloating gas and diarrhea why
include a postbiotic well it provides
fuel to the cells that make up the gut
lining and supports a healthier gut
barrier that means it's win-win and a
delayed release capsule just like their
multivitamin is designed to help survive
the harsh conditions of the upper GI
tract for delivery to the colon which is
the ideal place for probiotics to grow
and Thrive it's an all-in-one single
nested minty capsule that tastes
delicious minty capsule with no
Refrigeration needed so it's easy to
take with you when you travel proof
proof uh what's a proven Point case in
point I have it with me here in Portland
ritual when I leave I have a lot of
supplements that I take at home but the
only ones that I always take with me are
my ritual uh symbiotic plus and my
ritual multivitamin so symbiotic plus
and ritual are here to celebrate not
hide your insides it's time to listen to
your gut ritual is offering my listeners
10 off during your first three months
visit
ritual.com weird to start ritual or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today that's ritual.com
weird to add to start rituals or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today and show your support of this show
alright everybody let's get back to it
uh what's the greatest lesson you've
learned about acting because I I want to
make sure you
hear this Dad
it's good because you were looking oh
that's totally fine it was a reference
to my dad not listening to me
um I think you're a phenomenal actor
you're one you're one of a kind
you are constantly working and I know
why what you do no one can do exactly
what you do like you do it and it's
phenomenal and hilarious what it what is
what are some of the great advice you've
gotten about acting maybe from Aaron
Sorkin I'm just kidding but like what do
you try to hold in your mind or not hold
in your mind but think about before
you're doing a scene before you're
performing on stage or in a movie or
whatever it may be do you like acting I
do like acting why do you like acting
because it's play it's playing it's
listening when you're doing it nothing
else is happening so it's very tunnel
visiony you know especially if it's a
small scene if it's a scene with like 30
people like a big dinner and all I have
to do is here here like right that's not
my favorite no but if I'm in a scene
like this show I did crashing a lot of
scenes where it's just Pete and one
other person talking right that's the
kind of stuff I like to do uh so I like
do you like playing characters or you
like playing yourself
every character I do is I'm still in the
version of your version of me yeah still
I I but you've also done uh like
sketches where you play sketches I do
bigger things characters like
personalities I like that a lot but
finding that like something that would
work in between like a sketch where you
can do like a big big choice and nobody
questions it right I just did a guest
star on something and I was doing
something and the director came up and
they were like it's getting a little
bill in Ted's and I was like this is the
risk this is why I never wanna and they
were right by the way they protected me
but that's why I never want to make like
a big
what's going on like something like that
right because I didn't want to be
embarrassed right but but tell me about
that what do you do when you create a
character are you are you worried about
being embarrassed and do you like acting
I always am
worried about being embarrassed but
what I've learned was that's
the
place you need to go to create something
that is
true to you
like you can't
you have to be aware of that but
basically I like to
to
push it
and make
not big choices but strong choices
um and try to with the tools that I have
or whatever or the knowledge I have from
the years of
doing what we do
uh to try to ground it because my
feeling is
as long as it's coming from
a I'm going to use real place quotes
um so dirty now yeah it's very dirty
right
um let's do this real place you know as
long as you're grounding and and making
it is you know true to you as you as you
possibly can knowing that it's all make
but we're let's all make believe
um then then strong choices or big
choices are fine
uh can you tell me a time when somebody
came in and was like Kenny boy uh let's
tone it down
nobody ever went maybe take out the fake
teeth
no I mean you know I mean you know well
I don't
I
[Laughter]
I'm sure again I mean this goes back to
the other thing we were talking about
I'm sure people have said that to me and
I've made the adjustments but then I let
that go and I didn't get all like heard
about it that they thought maybe the
choice I made was too big my job is to
come in and
create a character and a and and do the
you know respect the lines and respect
the text but also bend it to the way
that I can only be I always think about
acting as
I think scenes are music
and I think that we are supposed to be
you know musicians of some sort right
and we're supposed to so like and and
it's sort of jazz right so like it's
like you're gonna bend the notes
differently than I bend to notes but the
way you bend the notes aren't wrong it's
just that you your interpretation of it
that is grounded and real to you
from your experiences in life and
that's how I approach
um the text and and and scenes where I
I'll look at them and I'll try to like
respect what the writer's intentions
were and recognize what the structure of
the jokes are if it's comedy
um or what the structure of the scene is
and what how I'm supposed to serve the
story
but then I also want to
bend it to make it mine because
um I can nobody else can do what I can
do and nobody else can do what you can
do because you're you and I'm me and so
if I can stay true to
making it truthful and believing my
choices then it will be interesting and
it might not be the right thing the
director might not like it or the
writers may say that's not what we had
in mind
um but I have found that more times than
not with that confidence
usually
it's liked by the writers and it's liked
by the director yeah
um I really admire that I'm not just
saying that I think that's really cool
does that make sense absolutely I think
right so do you base it on a person when
you do it like I I'm really new at the
idea of like I want to build a character
and the closest I can come as I go like
well my brother sort of holds his body
like this and my friend uh Ernie kind of
when he talks he does that are you just
kind of going with your instinct in the
words I think it's a bit of both I think
it's so
so did I mean like did you study acting
at some point not really so I went a
little bit a little bit and what and
what was the
philosophy or the teacher or the
technique or whatever my teacher my
professor Norm Jones had us go out and
watch someone walking that we didn't
know and then mimic that walk and then
build a character based on that walk and
I really wish I had done that because I
just did a walk of somebody I remembered
in high school and then I so it was
based on someone I had seen but just
from memory and then I turned it into a
cop which that walk wasn't the Walk of a
cop like looking back I was like that
was completely wrong and I just kind of
picked well but even if you pick
somebody on this oh so you were supposed
you knew it was supposed to be a cop no
I what I did was I backed it into
something I was comfortable with instead
of being as vulnerable as the exercise
wanted me to be which is like pick
somebody walk like them be in their body
you know and and try it on and then let
their body as you interpret it they're
gone now dictate what do you think they
do for a living how do you think they
talk how do you think they smile how do
they I think they laugh I was too
embarrassed and scared to really do the
exercise but that was something I
remember doing in an acting class and I
wish I had taken it more seriously
what was yours
well I just feel like
the way you
build a character if that is you know
like I like
I went to
I went to NYU and I studied you know
this is where I'm at the state guys but
I wanted to be an actor I was
desperately wanted to be an actor and I
never thought I wanted to be a comedian
I just thought I wanted to act
and so the four years I was there I was
doing the state we were doing shows but
um I was also studying at least
Strasberg Institute right and you had to
pick up where they put you in a place
and his whole thing is like working from
the inside out right and then there was
Estella Adler is working from the
outside in right so create a character
create a walk what are they wearing what
are their shoes right that's one
approach right and then Lee strasburg's
thing is like this sense of memory of
like where you know where is it coming
from like what is the how do you get to
those feelings through you know some
sort of deeper emotional thing that
you've experienced and how do you kind
of
figure out a way to bring that back on a
consistent in a consistent way or when
you need it in front of the camera or on
stage every night or whatever
and all of and a lot of there I have a
lot of friends who are like all that all
that is [__] just pick an attention
go up and say your line and I'm like it
might a lot of it might be [__] or
it might not speak to you but like it's
all I don't think it's all [__] I
think it's it's all
interesting and if you can find things
that speak to you
and you know that some of the Strasbourg
stuff spoke to me and some of the Adler
stuff spoke to me and some of the
Meisner stuff smoked me a lot [__] you
know and I just took little things from
that and little things that I
experienced and
and so
I don't know I don't I like at this
point I just I I feel like you just want
to
read the text see what the
see what the writers
what their intention is or try to
interpret what their intention is try to
respect that and then
have feel something like in like you
know when you're going back to the music
like when you're
you're playing jazz you know what the
notes are but you're going in places
that you're just you feel like are right
right in the moment
so to give yourself the freedom to do
that while making one or two specific
choices about a character either
externally or internally right saying
okay I'm going to find something that
kind of makes me go to a place of
whatever pure happiness or sadness or
Melancholy whatever the thing is and I'm
going to
and you know the party down I I feel
like the guy is you know recovering
alcoholic and I I want him to have a
military kind of buzz cut because it
shows that he's in charge and he's also
showing him when he looks in the mirror
that he's to stay on course right those
are the so those are those the haircut
yeah oh wow and so I can't picture that
character without that haircut yeah I
mean I mean it was but but it was you
know then they could have said no we
don't want you to do that and I would
have been like okay and then I would
have picked something else but they were
like yeah you could do that
so
that's brilliant so you know I just you
pick a couple of things and then you
commit to them that's such a [__]
long-winded way of I loved everybody
talking are you not acting that was
great I loved it and is there great
advice you've been given is there
something that people
it could be simple it doesn't have to be
great but like a great piece of advice
you got about acting or about comedy
I mean I love to watch
old clips of Comedians and actors
talking about acting and comedy and the
approach to it the thing that I've
always and people always say
comedy and drama are different
and
I I always feel like
they're not as different as
I don't think they're enormously
different I think you just need to kind
of
commit to what the text is and
make choices and
um
so I I like I guess
I feel like
um for comedy I just feel like as long
as you're
and I don't know who said it or Whose
advice it was but like treat it like a
drama and
you know I'm aware of having done sketch
comedy and I was laughing because I was
thinking about I didn't want you to
think I was laughing at your answer I
was thinking about the new Lord of the
Rings show and how dramatic it is right
and how funny it would be if you were
just like run to the waltz it is funny
like if that was in a comedy same
performance same performance it would be
so funny but when I watch it in drama I
always think about the boom guys over
there and someone's like buy the sword
of Israel and I'm just like this is
hilarious yeah just when you watch a
drama you go like it's okay this is okay
this is what this I guess this is how
they talk and
if it's if it's a dramatic thing you buy
it and if it's a comedic thing you buy
it and
I I don't know I mean I uh just making
sure they buy it you just make you just
make it truthful but oh what I'm saying
is like but you know yes in a comedy you
might want to make some bigger choices
but you still have to commit to them and
make sure that they're not just
for the the laugh yeah like you have to
make sure that they're grounded in some
sort of Truth for the character well
when I met you with Ben Sonic the
Hedgehog uh I told you which is true
that wander less what you wrote and are
in uh is one of my favorite movies of
all time and when I see your face I
think of you going a very big moment if
we could talk about it you're talking
about how you're in the porta potty
business
and for people that haven't seen the
movie you're sort of representing to
Paul Rudd's character just sort of the
grotesqueness of the American dream how
you can get so up your own ass thinking
that if you make money it's good and if
you have a mansion you're happy and you
you turn a blind eye to the Michaela who
I love dearly because clearly on the
edge like she's she's crying for help
she's going to explode suicidal she's
suicidal exactly and you're over there
thinking you're the winner like you're
Captain America because you're a
millionaire and as you're explaining
this to Paul which eventually talk about
serving the story motivates him to go to
a commune which is brilliant in fact
just like a good hero's journey they go
to the commune and then they leave this
is called resisting the call it's a
great mechanism you want them to stay
you think they're going to stay but of
course everybody resists the calling
they resist truth and then they go and
stay with you and you have the moment
this is the moment I really wanted talk
about where you go like every time you
see a porta body that's money in my
pocket and you go
it's a big swing and it's hilarious is
that a good example of what you mean by
like sometimes in comedy you make a
bigger play yeah
I guess I knew it was but I just wanted
to talk about it yeah I mean
I mean I knew the tone and tenor of the
of the piece that we were doing mostly
because you know Dave and I wrote it
yeah and so I knew that would fit in the
tone of the movie right that sounds so
um I knew that that was in the ballpark
now we may not have used it because you
know we made and editorial we may have
been like uh too much in that moment
yeah but I knew I wasn't going to be
like completely off base but even so
even if you I think you need to in
acting
be willing to be
uh to take those risks and be willing to
fall on your face which is not it which
is such a cliche thing to say I'm not
saying anything new I think you are
saying something new but but
um here's the thing that is tough to do
early in your career it's hard to do it
because you're so because if you [__] up
you feel like you're never going to get
another chance
whereas now in my career
right out of the gate I'm gonna go do
what I think is the right choice as
opposed to uh
uh being a little hesitant to to do it
respecting the text respecting the the
type and tone of the show that I'm on
but I'm going to take a big swing that
doesn't mean it's a big choice but I'm
going to take a
I'm going to drive the scene the way I
think the scene should be kind of
driven
um and then it's up to the director and
the producers to be like
no or great let's modulate that let's
you know because it's because you are
vulnerable when you're in front of the
camera and you're you know you're just
giving stuff out there and so there are
times when I've done stuff and nobody
came and corrected me and then I looked
at it and I went oh
different it should have been for a
maybe a different movie but like I you
know and then it's your job to take that
risk but you yeah it's your job to to
kind of give them something and then
they can you gotta
trust yourself but you also have to
trust that they know what they want and
so
they'll come in and
mold it if they need to or they'll be
like great that's great and what was the
writing process for Wanderlust line Dave
and I wrote several movies
um uh but we lived we wanted to write
something together but we were living on
separate coasts and we decided to
um we did this thing where we would lock
ourselves in our uh a room for seven
days straight and we worked for 12 hours
a day
and the goal was to come out with a
first draft of a script in seven days in
seven days and we did that for the 10
which we did and then we did that for
Wanderlust
and we did a version of that at a
necessity because it was already in
pre-production and going but we did a
big rewrite of Role Models David was
already attached to direct
um slightly different than the other two
but we would lock ourselves in a room
for 12 hours straight seven days
straight and the goal was to come out
with a a first draft and then of course
it would take a year to rework it you
know
finesse it but we had that hard copy
which is
the hardest thing the hardest thing to
do right and then you and you could feel
it and it motivated you you're like okay
we have a story now how do we make it
really good we have the bones now let's
add some meat to it the proper meat to
it yeah
so we did that with the 10 and then we
did that with uh uh uh Wanderlust and
then we did that with another movie that
we didn't make but um so 12 hours
12 hours a day literally yeah so we
would so we would get together because
it was at it was out of necessity
because we weren't able to
uh you know we were both working on
other things so we're like okay let's
take this week
put it on the calendar and we're gonna
bang out a first draft and then we can
go back and forth on you know whatever
so you guys would do this together like
in the room in the room together
no David is a faster typer than I am and
so David would mostly type and we would
just and I would stand there and we
would act stuff out and and we would
bang it out
um what it what is the phone and break
and food policies here
so the way it would work is
um uh uh we'd have lunch
and there'd be food in the house to
snack on and
um
that would be it and so you know uh we
we the structure was the first two days
the first day come up with an idea
and within the first two days have a
outline
on a board
and then the next five days was 20 Pages
a day
well
and
uh
uh that's what it would be and so we
would
I think it was the first 12 hour or the
first six hours
any throw anything up on the board any
ideas it's movie This Is the movie and
how about a movie about this how about a
movie about this then the second half of
the day and this full next day was
at lunch decide what the idea is then
um and we can come in with ideas like
you know it's not like yeah don't come
in you know so David that sounds planned
yeah right but but uh but you know and
then but then we would go okay let's now
let's outline it okay the First Act is
here's some you know cards here's what
happens in the second act and the third
act this has happened right and then
that's done by the and we write it out
we put it on the board and that's done
by the second day and then 20 Pages a
day wow
and then at the end it's what's fun is
like you finish it and it's a god it's a
mess it's an absolute mess because like
all the ideas you had for the last two
or three days
weren't represented in the first two you
know two days of writing the 20 pages of
the first 40 pages but you've figured
out your answers to the first 40 pages
so like so then we don't read it for a
week or two and then we both read it and
then we talk about it and then that's
when we start to rewrite and what made
you want to do a movie about a commune
we had watched some
uh Swedish movie
called together I don't know why that
made me laugh some Swedish it's called
together and it was really good and
there was a a scene about
an open a couple trying to be open and
the guy sort of being slightly
uncomfortable with it
but like being like yeah let's do it and
we use that as sort of a jumping off
thing of like
sort of a seed to kind of build the
whole story around okay that's fantastic
and in the original version of
Wanderlust which we shot but then we
went back and did reshoots
um because it didn't test well
um in the original version and you can
watch it in the Bizarro cut I've seen
the bizarre uh she sleeps with everybody
at the commune like Jennifer sleeps with
Justin and then everybody else into
commune including Alan Alda who gives a
wonderful speech to Paul when he's
looking around for her I don't know if
you've seen that in a Bizarro cup but
um and then of course people when we
tested it we're like What Jennifer
Anderson sleeps with everybody in the
commune and she's not she doesn't feel
bad about it like we're like yeah that's
the she's embracing the whole concept of
the
um and so then then we had to see how
that might not dust well and we're like
yeah you think that people are gonna
love that or like yeah yeah
um so then we had to go back and make
her have regrets about it and then also
bring in a a
make Justin's character have a
instead of it just being a love triangle
he had to
be trying to screw the commune over and
sell it and not be really who he was oh
that was added that was added which to
me is fine
and I get it it reminds me of adaptation
have you seen adaptation yeah I love
adaptation and when Charlie Kaufman in
the movie realizes his movie isn't a
good movie and then it turns into a drug
Heist movie yeah yeah yeah I think it's
one of the most brilliant movies ever
because the movie itself has an
existential crisis and they're snorting
the Orchid
it's not wrong I've actually never
bumped as we say on the fact that the
commune guy was evil well originally it
was a smaller movie right and then we
sold it to Universal and so became a
bigger movie and their thing is like you
got to make it a bigger movie
essentially right
whereas when we did it it was just a
love triangle it was like Justin Jen you
know Jen's character goes there Embraces
the philosophy and Justin falls in love
with her and then wants to possess her
and and so he's no longer embracing the
philosophy like he's he's not true to
the philosophy of everybody loving
everybody
Paul's characters Paul's character who's
like whoa I I you know he just wanted to
have a little something on the side in
that moment he was titillated by it but
he didn't the philosophy never spoke to
him right
he just was like Hey wouldn't it be
great if I can sleep with Malin you know
like that was his whole thing right
um
and so it was just a love triangle thing
but then you had to make it a bigger
movie then we had to make it a bigger
movie and so he became a guy who was
trying to screw over the whole commune
as opposed to a guy who was just so
deeply in love with
Jennifer Jennifer's character that he
just wanted to possess her and and steal
her from Paul I see I love it and I need
it so well you got both versions
here's a question for you yeah but it
might I don't know how you do this it
might be just pressing pause you have to
pee you can put that right on your
dinghy
[Music]
I don't mind it
I I prefer it
[Music]
um let me ask you a question do you love
doing this this podcast yeah I do why
uh well a lot of the same reasons I love
doing doing acting which is
usually if I'm not getting double called
from my manager's office
I'm mad about it you're really upset I
don't know but that it takes me out of
it yeah uh
and and I was checking while you're
repeating what it was what was it
nothing nothing
[Music]
uh I like doing this because it's the
only thing that's happening it lets you
get into that bubble of just like just
another person just listening to them I
like the hyper focus of it I like the
the excuse I've said this a million
times but if when I met you I said would
you like to hang out with me for two
hours you would have been like oh that's
insane but if I said that's not true
though well with you because you're a
real bee love sweetie Petey can I call
you a sweety PD but you're really
sweetie you're a sweet you're sweet
relish
thanks you're a sweet pickle
um so I love that you would do that and
that you're living that kind of life but
you know take anybody else
Jason Alexander I mentioned Kevin Smith
right most people and I'm the same way
if you were just like let's hang out for
two hours just us and we'll just talk on
a couch everyone would say no to that
when I would say that's almost always
exactly what we need is to like just be
heard and to hear another person locked
on in conversation for a little bubble
of time where you're not looking at your
phone and you're not thinking about
anything else I mean what's better than
that well
I hear you and that's wonderful
for me I just think of like like
my uh but it's not just you and I
talking right it's because it's shared
because it's shared you get over that
pretty quickly though
I mean I did in in waves and moments
during this I I just so you understand
yeah yeah it's part of I have there is
an anxiety that I have brought with me
to this
part of it was in the not sitting down
bit not wanting to start right to avoid
the uh
the act of opening up or not even act
the
getting to a a place of opening up and I
think it's because
I
don't think I have anything valuable to
say
well you're not alone there
when I asked I told Jason Alexander it
was two hours and he was like I don't
think anybody wants to listen to me for
two hours isn't that nice here you are
and I'm I'm at least saying yes you do
you know what I'm saying right isn't
that a nice little message in and of
itself yeah that I've enjoyed it the
whole time and you did have plenty to
say for two hours yeah so you did
something you didn't know you had any
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but I know
what you mean I just you have to
understand I've been doing it for 10
years
so like you you over 10 years you do it
so much that you stop worrying all
together
about the reception
have you you think about the reception
but you don't worry about it
and
okay well I can ask you these questions
later
because I guess you're supposed to be
asking questions
um it's fine it's all good
[Music]
um
so what were we talking about oh you
have the last couple questions are you
ready are you excited and by the way
anything you said that you want to take
out you're allowed to no I don't think I
said anything that's really oh Jesus
until I go back and listen to it
Shoot Me Gently no no
99.999 of people don't do that I just
want you to know that it's not some
podcasts I do I've been on podcasts
where I'm like they know they're making
me uncomfortable or they're asking me to
like comment or weigh in on something
right I don't feel qualified or even
appropriate to weigh in on it but it's
like the Click bait moment and they're
like what do you think about Will Smith
or something like that and I'm just like
those I hate I don't like that yeah
that's why I mentioned I've enjoyed this
thoroughly yeah but I have um I think I
I think I you know get a little anxiety
I think talking about that is what we're
supposed to do yeah I feel that I feel
the same way it's not with podcasting
anymore
there's a certain
snowed in feeling to podcasts especially
established podcasts like the people who
are listening are the people who are
listening we get we get new people but
like it feels like a pretty safe and
cozy listenership Right audience that
I've come to trust and enjoy and that
that helps me not worry about it and and
not flare up with anxiety other things
do make me flare up with anxiety I'll
worry about something I said to somebody
at a party for example for a long time
I'm constantly doing this I just took an
ADD test and one of them was like do you
say things without considering the
ramifications and I was like
I just cackled while drinking wine out
of a skull
you know so yeah I have anxiety about a
lot of stuff yeah yeah yeah
um but this is this is not one of them
do you love acting you ask me if I loved
actor I do love acting yeah I love
acting
um I would be shocked if you were like I
don't because you look like uh I love
acting I love actors yeah I love being
around uh
uh just the whole kind of scene yeah I
love directing
um edit that out
um please uh edit that out now ah you do
want it edit it no I I um no I just saw
that you've been directing more and more
yeah I
um but acting is something I've wanted
to do since I was I think in third grade
oh wow and uh
which is weird and it's something that
I've
sort of in third and fourth grade I was
like I'm going to act and I've never
stopped kind of heading in that
direction and I've been very
very lucky to have
um
opportunities happen and things happen
and fall into place and people at in the
time during certain times when I was
questioning it
to come in and be like no keep doing it
like I've just it's just been
who gave you that pep talk
I mean there were people in high school
there were people in college
um
I feel like uh when I came out here and
there was you know there was a slow
period I had
um
a person kind of be there and give me
the
time and the
pep talk I needed to kind of continue
going
um but I
I I I I just I feel it's
super lucky to be doing the thing that
I've wanted to do since a very young age
and I love it and so I I think when I do
it
that's the thing I always
uh if it feeds me when I do it is my
like it's not it's not a
it's it's not something I I've lost
interest in or uh or I
did dislike I I mean I really just I
love
getting to
act with people and
um is there fun something you haven't
done that you want to do I think about
like Adam Scott for example just doing
Severance which was so cool I could
obviously see something like that like a
drama or even something scary with you
um you know what I mean like chilling
like yeah yeah uh uh you know
it
yeah I want to do it I want to do
whatever opportunity comes comes comes
to me and I've had the
luck to get involved in because because
a lot of the things I've done a lot of
the shows I've done have not gone a long
time right have not been
successful in as far as like being
picked up year after year I've had the
the luxury of doing a bunch of
a bunch of things yeah and a number of
those things have become culty right and
but but it's given me the opportunity to
do whatever Burning Love and Eastbound
and Down and uh you know party down and
um
you know uh uh the number number of
different things and so
you know the other two that I'm on right
now and
um uh
but they're okay
they're all comedies and and you know
it'd be interesting to do something a
little bit more dramatic but I'm you
know if that comes along great if it
doesn't fine yeah I'm not like
comedic actor who's like I need to do
some drama I've always wanted that I
mean it would be great and I think I
would have a blast doing it I think I'd
hold my own but I don't
but I you know I'd like to do a western
because they always seem like fun to do
yeah yeah like to enjoy being in like
doing a story that involves Cowboys and
horses you'd be a great cow that'd be
fine Tony although you know I don't
think I have the the uh the um no the
cowboy accent for it right that's still
two Long Island Long Island Cowboy okay
there you go uh Long Island Cowboy is
the name of the week Long Island Cowboy
you're perfect for it well there was a
there was a
many years ago
uh
James
did you know James Roday oh he's not
rode anymore is it James Rodriguez now
is it yeah I did a show with him and we
would always talk about doing a movie
called Dracula Dracula Long Island
Dracula Long Island so it's just all
along like heavy thick Long Island
accents and Dracula is very long island
and it's awesome you know
ah try some of his blood it's awesome
Dracula Long Island we never did it well
here we go this is the the questions I
ask everybody
have you ever almost died yes
um I have at it so I was I'd love to
hear I was uh
doing the state are you familiar with
the state yeah okay so the state
um was on MTV in the from 93 to 95
and uh in the middle of that me Mike
black Mike Showalter and Joe the truglia
decided we're gonna drive between
Seasons we're gonna drive cross-country
and dude and so we rent so we got one of
the vans that they use you know um what
do you call the the the the on set the
you know the 15 passenger kind of van we
pulled out the back seat and
put all our [__] in and made like a bed
in the back and like you know and we're
just gonna drive it was a passenger van
and we were going to drive cross country
four weeks five weeks
and we made it to
Austin Texas
within a week
and we were going to go from Austin or a
couple of weeks whatever and we we're
going to go from Austin to
uh Vegas
in one drive which is a long drive
that's brutal so we decided okay two of
us are gonna
be able to drink black didn't drink
and one of us is gonna just drive the
night shift
uh uh from Austin to where until the sun
comes up and then black will wake up
Mike black and he'll drive the next 12
hours and we'll make it to
uh Grand Canyon Grand Canyon I hate this
so I drove through the night so we so
everybody so everybody hung out parted
in Austin I drank a bunch of coffee I
party I hang out hung out with everybody
I drank a bunch of coffee and
drove through the night
through uh and then woke up Mike Black
when the sun came up you did it I did it
I got it
nodding off no strong strong
woke up black
you ready to drive no
are you ready to drive yeah I just need
a Dr Pepper so we pulled over at the gas
station he got a Dr Pepper
he started driving
in the passenger seat
seat belt on I'm in the seat behind
which is the long seat passenger van
right with nothing in between me and the
the front
not seat belt on
Showalter is in the next big long seat
and so when he flies forward he hits the
seat in front of him
black starts driving
for about an hour
I go to sleep and I hear a scream and
bumps
and we're driving off the road
[Laughter]
and
uh and we're running over these small
trees
running over small trees
but the car is on cruise control
so when it's hitting these small trees
and like you know like they're just like
folding over they're small like little
yeah
the car keep going boom keeps like
trying to get to 70 again he's on cruise
control at 70. and Mike black like is oh
and so he's preoccupied because when we
hit something I fly forward and go and I
turn right back and I go into the um
the the the charger that back then we
had a like a DVD charger that was sort
of like a cigar that you put in the um
cigarette thing yeah and so that hit me
in the seventh vertebrae so I hit that
and and black is holding me
and he's and he's trying to like make
sure I don't go flying all over the
place because we're just like
driving like this
and so the road goes like this and he
just like slowly drove off the side of
the road and it's and and then there's a
so finally we hit a there's like a
ravine that goes
like that
perpendicular to the road
and it's sort of like that so the truck
so so it's like a V so the the van goes
into it
the front wheels hit it blow out and
then it pops out right and then the van
stops
so
that's how we how that's how the car
stopped the van stopped are you in
excruciating pain right now I'm in shock
we're all in shock in fact the car
behind us watched it happen and so is on
the road about you know 50 yards from
where where we split off with them
and they get out and Mike black gets out
of the car and goes good morning that's
how that was his thing Showalter
immediately starts smoking cigarettes
with Joe trying to figure out where the
cigarettes are
and I'm
feeling like something happened to my
back
um
but about
50 to 100 yards up there's another
Ravine that goes not like that
because like that like a square
like a pit like a pit so if we if if
Mike had fallen asleep at the wheel
that's what happened yeah my fell asleep
too
why didn't he hit the brakes because he
was holding he was saving me from and he
just was like he didn't know what the
hell was going on
we none of us knew what the hell was
going on because we were all sleeping
including the driver
and so he was holding me this is not a
good ad for Dr Pepper so he this all
ends with he hits the so so if it was a
hundred yards further up if he fell
asleep just a little later he would have
we would have went into that Ravine and
that Ravine wouldn't have kicked us out
but rather we just would have stopped
going at whatever however many miles an
hour we were going wow 50 70 whatever
the and dead and I would have went
through the windshield wow
so I feel like that's a that's a great
one that's a that's the whole time I'm
wondering why Mike black just doesn't go
with the foot just just move to the left
you know when you're holding on to your
friend and making sure that he doesn't
fly out the window yeah I feel like
maybe he forgot to hit the brakes I
don't know I don't know what happened
yeah let's call him up they're right
there there they are it's right next to
the thing but I I understand it thank
him so much it did happen very fast yeah
and that's what happened and then you
wait for toe and did you ever make it to
the grandkids I went to no we I went
into a hospital in Sonora Texas which is
like right on the uh borderline uh board
which is right on the border between uh
Mexico and Texas I think it was Sonora
13 bed hospital I was the only person in
the hospital I learned to eat cream uh
cottage cheese and appreciate cottage
cheese for the first time
never liked it but then it was great
like I don't know if you've ever had the
cottage cheese in Sonora Texas
there's a particular
Hospital in Sonora Texas where the
cottage cheese is unbelievable you
take what I would do is take a couple of
painkillers right before yeah yeah
that's going to help you know what I
mean or if you if if you're open to it
get into it pretty extreme car accident
and then then try to cut it with PE
peaches canned peaches I'm not sure that
was good I think you might remember I
remember loving it
I think you were very high I was alive
yeah happy I was alive and I was like
this kind of cheese is the I will eat
cottage cheese for the rest of my life
that's the second there's of three is do
you think when we die is it all does
Consciousness survive the body or is it
over I don't know either
I don't know what do you think
yeah
I do I mean I don't think uh
yeah I I don't think Consciousness
anything happens to it ever I think it's
the real you what you really are
was never born and will never die but
Ken will go
but the real you is fine what is the
real me tell me what's looking at your
eyes right now awareness itself that's
what I would say that that energy
you could call it energy I would just
call it knowing the part of you that
knows your experience exists exist after
we go yeah I know the materials world
view is that that knowing is a
phenomenon that the brain developed to
survive the spiritual worldview is the
opposite that the Consciousness
developed the physical to play with
itself essentially
do you want to smoke some toad
no no so so
assigned to die yeah what happens here's
the best way in my view in my view
the whole thing is is awareness is
knowingness is consciousness is the
quality of being
and if we imagine that like water you
are a swirl of water you're the activity
or the play of that Consciousness
briefly and momentarily manifesting is
something that I call Ken and I'm a
swirl of water like this and when that
swirl is over and I dissipate into the
water nothing's been added or taken away
or nothing has really even happened just
that swirl stopped happening but I
merged back into myself here's another
energy you could say it's energy yeah
energy is good you're a glass of water
and when you die I pour you into the
ocean that's another way to put it the
way that uh Chinese then puts it is uh
when you break a Vaz the air inside the
Voz just goes into the air
but it's all the same kind of idea that
you're the heir and briefly you thought
you were the Vaz but the whole time you
were the heir wow I like that yeah
Joseph Campbell said we're we're
electricity and we've mistaken ourselves
for light bulbs
so you think when the light bulb breaks
the electricity is gone but really it's
just the thing that was holding that
current of electricity yeah
these are good things to hold on to
because we're all going to croak well if
but is the is the
point or the desire to just know that
some there is there is why do we have to
why do we feel like we need to know what
happens next well you're right I think
that is an ego trip and it can even
border on narcissism that you're like
clearly I must continue I want to know
the nature of being itself because it's
who I am I want to know myself
it's not so much that I want Pete to
continue I'd just like to explore the
phenomenon of awareness that's that's
right inside of me that I that I am
essentially
but does
that theory give you some relief
of course
if I thought I was Pete and it's all
over when Pete's over
what a bummer but if I why why is it a
bummer yeah you're right I guess I'm
just I'm trying to understand and I've
I've been all over the place with like
what I think as far as in terms of
answering that question yeah tell me
well no I mean I've been you know all
every different like I you know I
thought there was a heaven for a while I
thought that I do feel like we're this
energy that moves on I feel like we're
reincarnated I feel all every every
every time I hear something I'm like oh
actually that's pretty interesting too
yeah yeah but
I keep coming to the place of like why
do we need to answer that question like
you don't what is what is the what is
the value of answering that question
relieving suffering if it causes you
suffering to think that it's all
meaningless this is this is not my
feeling but if you're like this is
[__] but I don't think it's
meaningless I don't think I'm getting
that sense strongly that you don't right
which is why you're not plagued with
with needing the answer which is great
which is I think how we're supposed to
be
but if on your deathbed you go like I
don't want to go I don't want to go it's
that's all it's all the big Blackness
and all that sort of stuff you would be
you would be comforted to to remember
a cup of water pouring into the ocean
right you're just going home is another
way to put it right right right right
right right you're just returning to the
source that you're not going anywhere
that nothing's really happening it's
where the water going into the ocean all
that sort of stuff so if it relieves
suffering that's great yeah if you're
not suffering and I say this almost
every time when the when the guest turns
it back on me Buddha says
when you ask why where life came from
and what happens after we die he goes
That's like you got hit with an arrow in
your leg and you keep going who shot the
arrow he's like you've been hit with an
arrow just get the arrow out and take
care of your leg right don't worry about
who shot the arrow don't worry about the
why just take care of suffering relieve
your suffering relieve other suffering
help each other don't don't worry about
the the big answers because they're not
really for us to have
does that make sense it does it it's
it's
um
it's um it's a lot
it's good lot I hope yes of course I
mean it's you know it's it's
just it's it's such a
crazy thing to think about
um I guess for me
it's
I I want I've stopped thinking about it
because
of
of all the
I just feel it just feels like it
doesn't ultimately it doesn't matter
and I'm and right does that make sense
like it doesn't
I think a nice way to put that is
there's nothing to worry about there's
nothing to worry about there's nothing
to worry about there's nothing to worry
about that's a nicer way to put it
it doesn't matter it seems powerless or
whatever but I think if you asked well
it is powerless right
yes but there's nothing to have power
over any anyway you know what I mean
like you can surrender right you can
trust is another way to put it if you
don't like the word surrender you can
trust it I like what we came up with
there's nothing to worry about I think
if you ask
the enlightened people that have lived
that are living you say is there
anything to worry about
unanimously they would say there's
nothing to worry about yeah that when
they meet God when they have God
encounters or God just being a word for
the origin for the beginning when they
meet the essential nature of what we are
they meet a lover not a tyrant they meet
something that's seducing us that
Delights in us for sure that we can
trust for sure that wants to play with
us
uh all of that sort of stuff but it's
not malicious or horrible so the bet but
you realize this is what what you're
feeling
which is gorgeous a lot of people need
help to get there because they were told
about the scary God the alcoholic dad
God the the devil all these sorts of
things but if you can just get quiet and
look at what you are
maybe there's breathing techniques
there's meditation all that sort of
stuff but if you can settle down and get
into it we're back to being left you go
like oh this whole thing is is the
Delight of a giant yes
and you are that yes and deep down you
are that yes and that yes can't be heard
the
I think about when you ask that question
about
not where I go but like the people who
are
still here dealing with death right in
somebody else's death
more and more as I get older I think
about
it's not about it doesn't matter
where I go where I think I might go or
what happens or whatever it's more about
like the the biggest
fear or
um
uh the uncomfortable part for me is like
saying goodbye to
the the the the people I love here yeah
right sure
not about where I'm going and wanting
them to be okay yeah well I think that's
gorgeous
it's beautiful
the you again this might be too heady
but I think and I've written this down
and I'd probably put it in a book or
something but when I tell my daughter
there's nowhere you can go that I'm not
with you I actually think that's
literally true because I think
underneath all of this and underneath
all of this we're the same thing right
because the Vaz is broken and you're
exactly we're all here we're all there
which means when you die
I get it
you're leaving but really
I'm always here yeah where where could
anything be right
right that's beautiful right so but
that's beautiful that's what I would
tell my own daughter on my own deathbed
I would just be like literally I'm not
going anywhere I hear Ramona marshy a
great Indian Saint said his devotees
were saying when he was dying they say
don't go don't go and he goes don't be
silly where could I go and that is the
perspective of an enlightened being
somebody that understands what's going
on is that we're perceiving what's
happening linearly but really
it's just
the Jewish tradition will say God is one
look to any other faith for other ways
of saying that it's all one yeah so
don't worry that's beautiful that's the
whole thing well you you you're really
representing it man I love
how fearless and unencumbered and and
how loving you are I think it's really
special
no thanks especially for somebody that's
so talented a lot of comedians come in
and they and they have a lot of like but
you know and you're just kind of like
you're like your outfit very by the way
speaking of which I don't know if we
said it on camera this was a
this was a this was a uh what was it Mr
this was Mr Turk Mr this was for um you
know I know it's past Labor day but
the Heat and everything it's it's worth
coming in I'm so glad we had that that
little God chat and brought to you by
mrturk.com
I believe yeah it's for for 10 15 15 off
no I thought it was all purchase okay no
it's tough okay good here's the last
question
um can you tell me a time in your life I
know we burn the bridge this is how I
say it about my memory I go the bridge
is on fire behind me like it's burning
as I'm crossing
um with that in mind
with no pressure
can you remember the first thing you
said to me today I'm just kidding in you
no no I know can you think of a time in
your life that you laughed so hard you
were crying your belly hurt
um it doesn't have to be I always say
this but it's true it doesn't have to be
a great story
it could have been in college it could
have been when you were eight years old
somebody fell somebody farted a dog
walked in the room just like something
but even if you can't remember the
circumstance if you start with how old
you are who you're with
uh that sort of thing
it's such a bummer because like you
can't I I can I can remember crying I
can I I know I've cried so hard I've
left I mean I'm I know I've laughed so
hard I've cried right right I know that
happened
in a number of times the state time were
there ever times on set here's a good
way to put it but I don't I don't I
can't remember I cannot for the life of
me in this moment tell you
a specific I was clearly the accident
was right there yeah for your answer but
I don't know let me give you this hook
to see if you can pick it up with us
you're doing a scene in something you've
shot and it's so funny you keep ruining
it because you're laughing
erection selection were you on the set
that day he was on the set that day I
don't tend to laugh again I think it's
because
everything's I don't get too high or too
low that like I don't I don't feel like
I break too much yeah
and things and so I don't know I don't
know I know things make me laugh wait
let me ask you this then this is what's
your fart policy with your wife you're
ripping them
um and if she gives me the look of like
stop ripping him I'll stop for a while
but like you know I enjoy a good like
fart and I'd like I like I like farting
loud lately you know when I when I put
on a little weight you know like it's
interesting to listen to How the fart
sounds change right because they're
passing through a little bit more skin
so they go now
you know unless it's a real like heavy
one that goes
right but like when I'm doing my you can
tell your weight by the sound of your
fight yes I could play you three for
sure I can tell you yes yes yes because
like as if I'm like if I'm down to like
good fighting weight for my age right
like
you know it comes out like wow right but
if I'm but if I've been eating a number
of hamburgers and some french fries and
uh I'm not working out every day
consistently uh my butt will not be as
tight and so it will be like
I gotta get to the gym I gotta get to
the gym it's my it's my butt telling me
time to hit the gym oh my God and then
sometimes if my wife
or myself if I don't or or well there's
I mean we can get the whole fart
conversation but I know that but like
sometimes if I've showered and I'm just
just showered I'll reach down and like
an easy release and I'll like pull One
Cheek out spread freezing release
yeah right do one of those yeah yeah but
you really gotta
because sometimes you do it and you
think oh it's fine I've I've done I've
pulled enough butt cheek away to get it
out but no it still goes pop and then
it's like I you know and and like my
wife
and I'm like I I try to do it quiet but
then sometimes when you do the little
ones right yeah sometimes for some
reason that means the stink is like
it's worse it's worse and is that
because it because when it comes out
with a like sort of scatters it
scatters the smell but when you like let
it have a clear Lane
right it's like potent it's like intense
oh yeah it's like bear spray it's like
it's like bear spray and then it's like
God damn it I should have just made the
sound and then the stink wouldn't have
been as bad when you make the sound it's
like those little play vacuum cleaners
that toddlers use that it moves the
smell all around it moves every
direction right and so it's like you get
a little bit but it's not but not a bear
spray but the bear spray
I feel like you and I we didn't laugh as
much as I wanted us to laugh huh because
you're so funny
and you're so
quick and great with jokes and I wanted
to
um let I wanted to I wanted to
I wanted to talk about things that
weren't I wanted to talk about surface
jokey things to keep it lighted if you'd
like to do more bits so so I'm sorry if
I didn't do enough bits you're silly you
listen to benchwartz who when I asked
him to do it he said I'll only do it but
I don't want to go too deep so you
listen to an episode where I was like we
won't go deep but this is a regular
episode
I know but now yeah I hear you yeah
laughs here
uh what happens when we die here so you
nailed it but I really just
have to say I think you're terrific and
I do love how you interview people and I
think that
um you're very
connected to who you're talking to and I
really appreciate
um your style oh I really mean not just
in podcasting but in um your stand-up
and in your the shows that you do thanks
man um I think you're uh really
fantastic that's so kind I really
appreciate it and right back at you I'm
not just saying that been a huge admirer
for many years and I was
too shy I it took a lot of bigging
myself up to ask Ben
we were on the phone because we're
trying to be friends right like regular
Friends by the way he did the thing does
he do the thing he he said let's have
three conversations yes and they're in
the calendar we do it yeah and we've
done it we've did we do a thing where we
have to have two or three lunches okay
and that's the lunch where I saw you but
I was nervous and I didn't want to
bother him because one of my biggest
fears is that my friends will think I'm
using them like I don't want Ben to
think I'm using him to get to you but
when I saw him I was like of course I
don't know that would be so cool and
then he mentioned it what a mensch
I'll tell you something else mentiness
begets mentioness because I've been
trying and not to Virtue signal like you
talking to Katie yikes no but I've been
trying like I was on set recently and
somebody mentioned that they couldn't
break into voiceover and I was like I
know the person that books all these
things I'll set up a meeting just do it
mention it up match it up mention it up
that's what you get Ben Schwartz said
I'll even say he Schwartz again he's not
Sonic I have a question for you I listen
to your Michael Showalter okay yeah
right
and you said to Michael I'm just curious
finally I got all the state members
I didn't say something like that I did
not something along the line and I was
like wait a second I got all the Stella
members is maybe what I said maybe it
was still a member I I sure as [__]
would hope so
so you've done black we've had black
Wayne and Joe Walter
I'm a I'm a comedy kid in the 80s State
members have you done who you could do
General truglio Carrie Tom Lennon I've
had Tom Lennon
in fact as I was sitting here I was like
God I got to stop just having the boys
on I gotta ask some of these ladies you
gotta get carry on I would love it are
you kidding me yeah some of these people
are hard to get a meaning
it's not as easy as just going on IMDb
Pro and uh firing off some random emails
it doesn't work you have to run into
them at a restaurant do you if you if
you ever want anybody's I would
appreciate that stuff because you just
pinched it because Carrie would be it
should be fantastic Kerry's the best but
sometimes I get grief because I have a
lot of dudes on and I'm like I if this
podcast could be 90 women I'd be
thrilled I love Maya Rudolph is one of
my favorite oh my God that was a great
episode Jenny Slade is one of my
favorite episodes of all time Emily Maya
you talked about a lot about farts yeah
I wanted to know if PTA was ripping that
PT ass yeah yeah yeah and I think based
on our answer yeah There Will Be Blood
if you know what I mean
ah it'll drink everybody's milk she'll
drink a few lactose intolerant
and that's a problem
thanks buddy this was incredible we have
the guests say the catchphrase at the
end the catchphrases keep it crispy it's
just how we sign off
uh uh okay
[Laughter]
keep it
the accuracy
[Music]
did it you did what we talked about the
whole episode you made a big choice that
was grounded what a great way to end
thank you you know where it all came
from
[Music]